we have a voicemail number that you can
call that number is 2192 David P here is
again a caller continuing to accuse me
of suppressing the truth about what it's
not even clear I think he's referring to
covid because that's what he's always
referring to
hey what's up
from Mass again he loved to make fun of
my accent how you doing man what I just
wanted to say uh with all the stuff
coming out that you're suppressing
um there's only two options here and
this is good
either you're too stupid or realize that
or you're in on it and buddy I would
never call you stupid
yeah you know one of the really I mean
there's a lot of sad stuff here
typically when this guy calls in he'll
refer to something like David you're
covering up that millions of people have
died from the vaccine or something like
that and it's like no I'm not covering
that up that's not real but there's this
other really weird thing that's being
lodged at people who just like report
the science about what's going on with
the virus and vaccines which is they
they suggest that you know why I by
saying I'm in on it what exactly would I
be in on what advantage would there be
to me like no you know no there's no
financial advantage to just telling the
truth about the vaccines there's no
personal Advantage other than yes it's
true if more people get vaccinated I'm
safer in people I know are safer part of
the conspiracy that assumes that you
know this idea of complicit in lying
about the vaccines and covid is that
there would be some Advantage conferred
by it and of course they can never
really explain what what that Advantage
is uh but no nothing has been covered up
and by the way when when uh in some
upcoming show
increasingly people are pointing to the
vares system v-a-e-r-s and saying look
at all of these reports of people who
died from the vaccine in the vayers
system I'm thinking of doing a video
where I actually I'll show you on a
screen share I'll go through the vares
system and show you how easy it is to
just say my brother died from the
vaccine and submit it and of course it's
not check I wouldn't actually submit it
I would just show you how easy it would
be to do this is what people are doing
people are submitting bogus reports to
the vares system and then those bogus
reports are being used by anti-vaccine
individuals and media outlets and
pointed to and said look at all of these
reports anybody can submit a report
there's no checking whatsoever that is
done on the bonus show today we will
talk about remember that Missouri couple
of lawyers who were waving guns last
June during the black lives matter
protest they both pleaded guilty to
misdemeanors they've been pardoned by
the Missouri governor yeah the
mccloskeys we'll talk about that on the
bonus show secondly we appear to be
between
two and five weeks away from FDA full
approval of the coronavirus vaccine uh
made by Pfizer will this really get some
of these anti-vaxxers vaccinated I don't
know we're going to talk about it and
lastly the Japanese government is
starting a program of publicly naming
people who are breaking quarantine rules
in Japan is this a good idea could it
lead to disaster what would happen if
the United States did it all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up and get instant access by uh
making yourself a member at
joinpakman.com I'll speak to you then